it seems like most people that truly
hate Kanye wouldn't be able to spot
Yeezys
that's true it's too easy though you
just go like wait what this is Kanye
what
um
these are my stepping in [ __ ] shoes
[Music]
welcome back to another care for Wars
where we are very careful boys Merry
Christmas thank you it is the holiday
season
of 2024.
that's when this video is coming this
video is coming out after Christmas
Merry Christmas we can't control it
um the system is what it is nothing you
can do it's like politics yeah no um so
our significant others don't really
watch the show maybe don't watch Clips
maybe they see it and they shouldn't
insta and they scroll by not subscribed
right mine doesn't until someone sent
the one where I was talking about how I
had anal for the first time someone sent
that to her yeah what the [ __ ] well if
she said it came up on her recommended
I'm like there's no way it did she said
it came up or did she say it exploded on
her recommendations
said it came up
she goes why didn't you tell me that
happened to you
do not bring it up in conversation
everything yeah
she's like you know I give you that good
I know so so we feel comfortable in this
room especially Behind these four walls
to save what we want for Christmas
because we know they're never gonna
[ __ ] see it and we trust our fans to
not spoil it that's right but we're just
gonna put it out there in Texas except
for the one who told the [ __ ] deck story
that's [ __ ] up don't do that again
[ __ ] dick stories are different from
Christmas gifts yeah that's different I
haven't had a Christmas present in a
long time that is extremely saddest
thing I've ever heard I'm no it's not
because no it is you've been a bad kid
every year
I think maybe uh people are going to be
like dude Joe you don't remember the
[ __ ] GIF I gave to it's probably like
something like that that's funny yeah
but I I think um I stopped caring about
gifts a while ago yeah that shouldn't
stop them from coming your way though
right that just makes you forget them
well for the past
oh you know what pre-covet we had the
Christmas parties we would do the gift
thing right but after lockdown everybody
stopped doing those things together
and even like when I had the family I
didn't have the family get-togethers or
anything like that so every Christmas
that was my you know how we go off in
December that was my travel time so I
was just off doing whatever while
everyone was having Christmas parties
and stuff but that was good
it's not sad I'm just telling you I'm
waiting for it not to be said okay we're
bummed out yeah the question is still
what do you want for Christmas okay so
so here's the thing
I I um I don't want things
but what I wish is no
I love snow better not be that dude and
eight ball of snow then it'll be sad
what I want to do is have a uh like a
white Christmas in this like like in in
the like in a cabin and I want to
[ __ ] deck out that cabin with a tree
and all that [ __ ]
and it'll be cool if like people want to
come down and we'll just chill and then
like do Christmas [ __ ] get some lift
tickets hit the [ __ ] hit the slopes bro
I'll hit the slopes I suck I like his
face he's down next Jake are you down
right now though aren't you [ __ ]
impaired
physical ailments you know does everyone
hear snowboards I've only been once
never been okay well no we'll be cool is
that there or is the bunny slope so then
the non-snowboarder group can go there
no no I just want to go straight for it
okay wow Colleen but I'm not waiting for
you because that's what always happens
no that's fine can I garbage can live
this [ __ ] is that chill huh what kind of
garbage can lid are you allowed to take
other things down the hill at Resorts oh
I don't know yeah because getting up the
ski lift is the hardest part well
actually at the bunny slope there's kids
doing other [ __ ] first basic one you
could I think you do whatever the [ __ ]
you want really yeah on the first one
yeah I probably will but that's what
makes it fun though because then you can
split up the groups because like yeah I
still like either one I'm not that good
didn't Sonny Bono die in The Bunny slope
skiing though is skiing a different
Beast I don't think it was a bunch did
he hit a tree though yeah he had a tree
it was the kid's point there wouldn't be
a tree in the middle of that [ __ ] no I
think he was on the kid's body slope I
think it was funny stuff's like flat
dude no I think he was on like one of
those are you would you guys rather have
gifts or like a an event like something
like that an event an event yeah
experiences but we're ruining the video
concept oh sorry I [ __ ] detoured it
no I like I like it though that's real
yeah his answer was good it was original
yeah it's real it's visual yeah because
then it's it feels like Christmas right
you're like in the snow and there's
trees and it's cozy and cold and [ __ ]
and then you're going out snowboarding
yeah that's fun caroling so you wouldn't
enjoy like being gifted a [ __ ] sick
snowboard
that's cool but then I'd rather go
snowboard with
so what do you want physically well
let's say we're doing the experience all
right what can I put under the tree for
you get back to me get back to me you
guys you guys do it yeah I gotta think
of something I gotta think of something
okay so I was at Costco recently and
honestly
this is a ridiculous gift
this is insane gift but I was at Costco
and I saw I was like holy [ __ ] and
actually me and Anthony were playing
this yesterday although he's not my
friend but yesterday we were playing NFL
Blitz together on this machine right
here and it was [ __ ] sick and dude
they had this so Ryan Ryan was like dude
I know what that is I was like dude I
saw a [ __ ] NFL Blitz yeah and it was
like in an arcade machine and Ryan's
like that's an arcade one-up machine and
I was like that's what the [ __ ] I would
want for Christmas but it's ridiculous
like five Hondo and I'd rather use it on
crypto honestly one you want in a way
that's a good purchase you spend 500 on
the cabinet right and you get the uh
software and the hardware in it people
you could spend a little bit more like
100 bucks and they'll put every other
game possible into that machine oh like
what he did oh that's tight
you'll never leave the house and that's
the point of wanting it for Christmas
because you wouldn't pay for it yourself
I wouldn't get it myself you bought
crypto yeah but hopefully somebody would
buy it right this year at DCA every
month okay but it's sick to have the NFL
Blitz designed cabinet yeah that's dope
they got Brett Favre on the side
he's my favorite welfare defrauder of
all time
he's the greatest welfare defrauder I've
ever seen he's my like it's not even
close I used to have a favorite well for
the fire and now Brett Favre is the
number one the best that's nice that's a
nice uh Christmas present I think that's
very good because I had so much joy me
and Anthony playing and even though we
were so bummed because we had to play in
the same team because we don't know the
buttons
in fact we had to play the same team
we're bummed so I was like I'm kick your
[ __ ] ass he's like I'm like [ __ ]
school and then we had to be in the same
team we got school we got school hard
but then
but there's fun in it we're like I'm
like hey wait to hit that and you you
can throw me the ball and he's like hey
if you hit that you can do a spin move
and it's mostly him just teaching me
because I forgot everything but it was
actually really fun it was really fun it
was really fun oh it's a moment but
that's right wholesome Blitz is for the
people which is it's for the boys so
good it'll bring families together
divided homes we'll come together for
Blitz but if it happened to us it can
happen to anybody if it happens [ __ ] it
could happen to Ukraine or Russia give
him NFL plays absolutely Putin [ __ ]
throwing uh throwing a a ball to
zelinski that that's Christmas and then
back slapping yeah this is like the
Christmas trees from World War One damn
a little earlier video reference there
it is what do you want for Christmas
um
I think it'd be more of an experience I
uh damn
damn dude that's really good that's sad
you thought my [ __ ] was not because
they're so no that's happy they're so
ridiculously expensive just to go to
Charlotte well that too that is just
like man I could buy like five tickets
throughout the year to see her but
there's so many people out there that
want to save you okay great you know
what I mean they'll send it right now
cash app right here oh my God give her a
Christmas present that she will never oh
Santa
I wish my wishlist was full and it's not
it's not just for me it's for my mom
yeah yeah yeah you're right two birds
you know what's cool about the JK fans
though you don't have to get naked for
them to send money into your cash out oh
so nice they're simps already yep yeah
they don't need you to give them
anything
but what's like a selfish gift you would
ask for yourself like
um not practical for you for clean yeah
that's right everything that I want is
just
so such a big ask of sterilites
no a red camera
yeah it would be like practical stuff or
experiences like traveling like to a
different country
of course she wants a seven thousand
dollar camera no yeah seven thousand
dollars a gold digger that's just the
lens itself how about a c-stand that's
the card yeah that self-deletes that's
what uh SD stands for top secret
self-delete that's where you're good
what about you Anthony dude let's hear
it I bet you got some cool [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] pay raise
whoa whoa wait we're not making it too
real making it too
that's like what do you want for the
next five Christmases what did Joe's
like all right after you get one okay
guys you guys get a 10 pay cut but he
gets a 40 pay raise one two three four
that worked right ten percent ten
percent ten percent temperature I
[ __ ] believe in Christmas happy
holidays everybody this video is brought
to you by Warby Parker have you ever
clicked around clothing sites and saw
some cool eyewear and you're like you
know what would be awesome is if I could
try these on but unfortunately I don't
like shopping for glasses online because
once they come they never look like the
way that they do on the website but
thankfully with Warby Parker they have
this cool little thing that I got to do
where I was ordering five different
glasses for free they show up and I can
try them on and see does this one look
good or does this one look good
Warby Parker offers everything you need
for happier eyes you see me smiling
through the smiles eyeglasses
sunglasses contact lenses and eye exams
and you can shop with them online or in
stores glasses start at 95 including
prescription lenses try Warby Parker's
free home try on program order five
pairs of glasses to try at home for free
there is no obligation to buy it ships
for free and it also includes a prepaid
shipping label so try five pairs of
glasses at home for free at
warbyparker.com off the Record wow
that's all I gotta say Santa's real
shake the pennies of our checks out onto
Anthony Lee's head that's what he wants
for Christmas if that's truly what you
want then do it
I want a coffee shop hey still on me
buddy let's actually die let's actually
go back can we go
after parter
um let's see I see I wouldn't I don't
think I would buy this for myself I
think it's too much of a splurge
but those Dyson vacuums have always come
dude which one the ball ones the pet
hair ones yeah any of them are cool
they're just so expensive I just it's
not that they're so expensive it's at
the the like 129 highly rated Amazon one
it's technically just as fine I guess
but I I don't know I don't know what is
it like three the Dyson ones like five
like 5.99 I don't know I've never
[ __ ] even touched Costco quite far
but yeah what would it make you want to
clean more if you had it absolutely it's
so efficient so so she's she absolutely
has to watch this video and the fact
that she's not going to it's really
gonna hinder it's so sad or Dyson could
watch the video and sponsor you hello
that would be sick I would also take one
of those heat cool purifier type things
that are back then I won't use my AC at
all right what's that bladeless fan for
me please yeah those are sick those are
sick I'll take a paddle board you took a
paddle board I'll take a paddle board
for Christmas yep that's what you came
up with you at 11 man yeah
yeah well I said a coffee shop but that
was unrealistic so a paddle board that's
cute that's like the most basic [ __ ]
kid thing like that wasn't that In Like
A Christmas Story
yeah it said Rosebud on it
that's a good Christmas gift that's a
pretty good one but I'd rather have a
coffee shop but it was probably gonna
take a while
once you get like one of those coffee
shops that's like made out of plastic
and like has plastic coffee and you pour
it to your little brother but nothing
comes out of the cup
is this decaf or those cups where it's
like black and then when you go like
this they it disappears those are so
good oh that's nice I had I had a
McDonald's a fake McDonald's playset
thing when I was a kid and it was
basically just my parents being like we
know what you're gonna do when you grow
up work at McDonald's you should be
ready one should be ready you do have a
McDonald's buy thank you I thought so
yeah
five but like a shift manager right yeah
you look jaded you look good in a visor
right there switch that hat with golden
arches
we got a McDonald's manager dude which
is fine
which is more than fine I love
McDonald's like I frequent there all the
time they're consistent they're the most
consistent chain in the world you guys
have a thing that if if it was like oh
man
if I didn't have any limitations on
money I want this oh yeah oh yeah
totally oh yeah for sure and and we're
not talking about practical [ __ ] like a
house or some [ __ ] right no it's just a
a Splurge yeah it doesn't have to be
like oh I need this dude those [ __ ]
indoor golf tracking things that you
have like you put in your whole garage
and you're just sitting there just
whacking at a [ __ ] projected screen
[ __ ] gives you all the [ __ ] info I
would [ __ ] bust a nut if somebody out
there saved me and got me one I want a
snowmobile but I want to hire someone
who drives snowmobiles really well so I
could be on my snowboard and be pulled
by it
uh that's really interesting I want to
ride the snowmobile too sometimes I
wasn't expecting that I thought you
didn't say I want a snowmobile but then
I don't have any snow so I need someone
to make snow while I'm on my phone
that's pretty sick and I also don't have
a mountain so I can get this I need a
mountain maker and a snow maker Nick
what do you want
can you come back to me yeah Nick's
gonna deflect here we go
I've been trying to wait [ __ ] 15
minutes to come up with something good
that you guys won't give me [ __ ] for
just say welcome to the show bro
what about like a silk ghee
honestly a nice robe would be cool
like a house robe hell yeah dude do you
do that I have I have a current robe now
that I really like but you know whatever
a silk one would be lit come on dude you
look like Jim Kelly like a Versace one
those are the most fanciest robes I
don't know if I can I would have I
wouldn't feel nice wearing those I'm
gonna wear ones I'm gonna wear one too
when we make it when we make it again in
crypto again I'm actually gonna buy
stuff with it this time well I did but
this time last time but I will this time
too so I'll be saying I bought a
stand-up desk what did you get
um look around my house all right the
whole bottom floor my loonies life yeah
I should have spent more at least I have
those I don't have the house because I
just lost all my money so what are you
gonna get other than a rope
man I really don't know man usually okay
usually for a Christmas so my wife is
always like what do you want to get for
Christmas and I'm like [ __ ] I don't
know and so she usually just buys me
clothes because like I need regular
clothes to wear like not [ __ ] gym
clothes because you notice every time I
come here I'm always in gym clothes if
she doesn't watch this and she gets you
a robe I'm literally it should plus 100
points I'll literally yeah I'll cry
that'll be Christmas spirit does she
know she got me one like a couple years
ago which is pretty sweet I still wear
it there's a Bad Bunny on the back nah
it's a bad boy dude no fear
tap out but you want another rope huh
but you want another room he said silk
and I was like yeah that's nice right I
can't low-key like actually now I'm
thinking about it I kind of want to get
a pair of Yeezys whoa hey while you can
right after okay it's [ __ ] up it's
[ __ ] up because I was at Disneyland
right before right before the Kanye [ __ ]
happened and my buddy had a pair of
Yeezys and I was like hey man I was like
asking him like it looks like hey man
you like these like dude they're the
most comfortable shoe he was selling me
on it and so many other people have like
corroborated his response about Yeezys
and I was like I'm gonna get some my
buddy has a shoe store in Pasadena I'm
gonna go over there because he sells a
gang of Yeezys but then the Kanye [ __ ]
came out and then now I feel bad for
buying Yeezys at this time what if I
might do I love NFL Blitz but I found
out they hate the juice
would you get out of the NFL Blitz yeah
because I had such a good time
keep it in your house like you if you
wear it out people will give you [ __ ]
for it my buddy he works up he has a
regular office job and he was wearing
some Yeezys and then somebody like
looked at his shoes and was like
so you support him
like after all this [ __ ] he goes he goes
come on dude it seems like most people
that truly hate Kanye wouldn't be able
to spot Yeezys
that's true it's too easy though you
just go like wait what this is Kanye
what
um
these are my stepping in [ __ ] shoes
that's all you gotta say yeah
even better you know I would love some
nice uh more basic t-shirts that'd be
good for Christmas
deflection that's not a deflection about
a slightly more splurgy be selfish what
do you want come on here I'll I'll tell
you what I want because this is splurgy
yeah maybe it'll make you a little
greedy all right I would like the one of
these two things and it's too much like
No One's Gonna Get me this [ __ ] but uh I
would like a new
roof for my van because the one on there
is rusted out and it's irreparable you
can buy van tops but they're pretty
expensive fiberglass things and uh that
would be a lot of money if not that I
would like to get a new motor for my uh
my Honda that I've had since high school
because now I replaced the motor once
and pretty much everything in it once
but I think the the new motor is now
dying and I would like to keep that
thing going so isn't that a couple Grand
just the front end swap well not the
whole front end but you just gotta buy a
the last motor I got was for like 600
bucks oh wow that come from uh Japan and
then I paid a guy like 300 to swap it
that's not bad dude this reminds me of
my buddy I love him he's the best but me
and him used to work on the show
together
is called Equals Three with Raymond
Johnson and he I remember him telling us
that like
if he put something on a list for his
mom she'll buy whatever the [ __ ]
everything all of it
and so like what you just said is like
you know I don't know who's been getting
a [ __ ] but like you know here's one
that's thousand thousand dollars here's
one thousand thousands of thousands of
dollars
but like discount would do that [ __ ] and
like he would just like
kick back and expect that shoot for
Christmas Christmas is his mom loaded
loaded what does she do on an Xbox and a
PlayStation and a Dreamcast like that
kind of [ __ ] oh Lordy Lord yeah when
we're kids like that we're like you're
the [ __ ] Emperor this is like the
dude from [ __ ] turbo man [ __ ] yeah
all the way yeah you [ __ ] hate it you
made it dude you're the [ __ ] King of
the Ring that's pretty cool damn that's
I'm not jealous you know what I started
doing when I had some extra income I
started buying the things I wanted when
I was a kid like certain Ninja Turtle
figures the thing that I just remembered
just having this conversation is I
wanted those dinosaurs that had lazy you
remember they had like saddles on a
dinosaur yeah I know what you're talking
about and it had lasers you could take
chunks out of their sides yeah and then
they built like it's like future right
and they had Wars it was like was it
from like my friend was called I think
it's called dino wars probably not
[Laughter]
hey do you guys remember that so
remember when we were kids and like
you're looking at like Lego playsets and
they had that [ __ ] pirate ship [ __ ]
yeah with the sails on it and [ __ ] that
was my favorite one favorite one yeah
nobody could ever get it because it was
like insane like inexpensive as hell the
biggest one right yeah yeah yeah it was
a lot now those are going for thousands
of dollars and like they're impossible
for even Lego fans to get whoa because
of nostalgia [ __ ] damn that was me I was
looking online on eBay and I was like
dude I remember playing with these toys
and I wanted the big pirate ship that
was the one I wanted yeah unattainable
you guys want to go down a [ __ ] hole
look up like Lego conventions oh yeah I
have those are nuts why why are they so
nuts
it's almost like they they build just
whole universes for these things and
then they explain every little detail of
it and then you're just kind of like yo
man I think you should have [ __ ]
worked somewhere else you should have
been an engineer or something do
something for Humanity yeah because they
they end up Machining parts that Lego
doesn't make in order to make certain
things come together like door hinges or
something and they're like this took me
like [ __ ] like 700 hours to glue down
and you're like with you yeah it's whole
like worlds it's crazy wow and then you
like look next to him and his wife is
her eyes are glazed over and she's just
like yeah I've been [ __ ] in a [ __ ]
decade but like you know in The Lego
Movie how the basement looks it's that
and that that basement is cute compared
to the convention I've been [ __ ] into
decades but the kids are all like we
love our dad our dad that's the best
Legos are the best and the mom's just
like like [ __ ] me
she because the camera guy she's like
[ __ ] me
see that's where guys need to go look
for girls like they're going Lego
conventions places
who are the cats you're watching this
morning oh the fashion fit should go to
the Lego conventions they'll clean up
the whole time
these [ __ ] can't wait they're so
horny hey before you go and turn those
off you got to say something you want
that's a Splurge the Splurge okay
all right you guys are gonna [ __ ]
make fun of me you want a Podium
what if you deserve it okay I really
okay so at the gym that that workout
yeah they got this really cool water
filter machine flow water no it's not
flow water but it's like it's like
reverse I don't know if it's reverse
osmosis yeah reverse osmosis [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] alkaline yeah yeah it's
probably all [ __ ] anyway but the
water is so [ __ ] good and all you
need is a water line yeah I need to get
one of those from my house yeah it's
like hanging water huh is it like Kangen
water oh what happened to the one you
guys had at the studio oh it's at
elements but it's it's so [ __ ] cold
you know what I mean it's like the
perfect Temple that's great dude and
some of them have like ice machines
I have no idea how we would even make
fun of you for wanting that
great I feel like you guys [ __ ] dunk
on me all the time there's a practical
thing you need you guys think I'm
[ __ ] full of [ __ ] all the time dude
no I mean I have a complex because of
you guys yeah that's good I get I get
why
what do you mean that was a good ass
well the thing is with those ones um I
think it's subscription based though
well they changed it it used to be like
you can just spend the money on the
machine itself but then they realize
they could make more money otherwise
yeah it's subscription based
everything's subscription-based these
days yeah I'm out it sucks wait Canyon
water no it's flow water that's the one
that's the giant flow water machine
superb what do they do just do
maintenance on the machine every month
they'll come by and replace the filter
and stuff yeah you can do that [ __ ]
yourself it's just the way if you want
that particular product yeah okay I
guess I'll just have to deal with the
dark but it's Christmas we're talking
about Christmas yeah that was a dumb one
though huh that was dumb that was a
little bit
stupid gift The Dark Knight is way
better
[Music]